- [Voiceover] This is the
third in a series of videos
about answering the
document based question,
or DBQ on the AP U.S. History Exam.
In the last video, we
started taking a look
at and analyzing some of the primary
documents provided for this exam.
So the first one was a folk saying about
how the boll weevil and sharecropping
had taken away African-American's
crops and homes in the South.
The second was a letter from a black man
living in New Orleans
asking the black newspaper
The Chicago Defender, to
help in finding him a house
and a job in Chicago.
The third was an article
in an industrial journal
counseling white factory
owners in the North
to segregate black workers
from white workers.
And the fourth, was an article
in a white owned newspaper talking
about race riots in Chicago, and how
African-Americans were better off
in the South, because they felt
that lynch law was better than
being killed in a race riot.
So there are three more documents
that we'll go through pretty quickly
and then we can get started on
writing a thesis statement.
Okay, this is a song
by an African-American
singer named Lizzie Miles, and the
song is called Cotton
Belt Blues from 1923.
Now I'm not going to attempt to sing this,
'cause you do not want to hear that,
but let's get a gist of what it's about.
Look at me, look at me, and you see a gal
with a heart bogged down with woe
because I'm all alone,
far from my Southern home.
Dixie Dan, that's the man, took me from
the Land of Cotton to that
cold, cold minded North.
Threw me down, hit the town,and I've
never seen him henceforth.
Just 'cause I trusted,
I'm broke and disgusted
I got the Cotton Belt Blues.
Well, it definitely seems like she has
experienced the kind of con man behavior
that the man in document
two was worried about.
So, she's saying that she was fooled into
coming up North for a man who has
now left her alone.
And she misses her home in the South.
But you could also think about
the fact that she herself
if we've got the lyrics to this song,
and this recording,
probably did pretty well.
So, this is more maybe of
an expression of popular
culture, and less of a particular story
about this person Lizzie Miles.
So we could talk about
the influence of Jazz
the fact that African-American's
came to the North
and influenced popular culture.
Alright, we're getting
down to the end of these.
Let's look at document six.
Alright, this document is from an
African-American journalist
named George Schuyler
whose writing in a magazine
called The Messenger
which was a political
and literary magazine
for African-Americans.
So, he's writing for a
sympathetic audience.
This is in August of 1925.
Schuyler says "It is generally thought by
both Negroes and whites
that Negroes are the
chief strikebreakers in
the United States. This is
far from the truth. The Negroe
workers' part in strikes
has been dramatized by virtue
of the striking contrast
of race which invariably
provoked race riots.
But the fact is, there are many more scabs
among the white than black workers.
Partially because there are numerous
industries in which Negroes
are not permitted to work.
Which too, are by no means 100% organized.
Out of 20 or more millions of workers in
the United States, less than
five million are organized.
Note the potential for scabs."
So one thing you definitely
have to know here
is what the word "scab" means.
So "scab", I think you can
kind of tell from the context
means strikebreaker, so
if a union goes on strike
a factory owner might hire
scabs or replacement workers
to try to break the strike.
So Schuyler is saying
there is a perception
that black workers are often used to break
strikes or that when a white labor union
would go on strike, the factory owner
might then hire black
workers, who of course
are going to have difficulty finding jobs
in a segregated economy, and therefore
they don't have to pay
the white workers more.
And Schuyler says that this is not true
it's actually just that
African-Americans are
so frequently barred from
industries, that they
can't be represented in
strikes because they're
not represented in
unions, or the places that
employ unionized workers.
Okay, last one.
This one is a map, and
I'm just going to put
it right here in front of everything,
because it's pretty large and if
we made it any smaller it would be
really hard to see.
So when you're looking at maps like this,
the first thing you want
to do is read the title.
Because that way you know what this map
is actually trying to show you, and you're
not just making assumptions
of what it could
be trying to show you.
So this map is about the distribution of
the African-American
population in Chicago in 1930.
What you can see here,
are that the sections
that are not shaded at
all, or shaded white
are less than one percent
African-American population.
The light grey is one to ten percent.
The medium grey is 10 - 50%
and then this dark grey is
more than 15% African-American.
And now what you can see here is that
it looks like there is a very,
definite African-American
neighborhood on the South side of Chicago.
Which, I think goes to show that
there's some real segregation
happening in Chicago.
And you can see here at the bottom,
it tells you, how many
African-Americans were
living in Chicago over
the 1910 - 1930 period.
And even though the
share of the population
more than triples in that time period,
everyone is set in this one small area.
So I think that goes to show that
even if you were a Southerner
who moved to Chicago
looking for a better life
as an African-American
you might still be subject
to this system of segregation
that would only allow you
to live in one neighborhood.
But there might also be a
positive flip side to that.
Which would be that this was
a thriving black community.
If you were a Southerner who had lived
in a relatively rural
place, you may not have
been able to spend that much time
with other African-Americans
as a young person.
So that's a possible
positive interpretation,
but we'll keep that one
the table just in case
it might help us with
part of our argument.
Alright, now we've read
all of the documents
and as we get started
on our thesis statement
I think one of the most
useful things you can do
is just take a moment and brain-storm some
of the themes have arisen
in these documents.
So what themes do we see here?
Well, I think that there's definitely
a theme about labor in general
not being able to do well under a
sharecropping system of labor
and looking for a good job.
And several things about factory work
whether factories should be segregated
or whether African-Americans play
a part in the labor movement in general
or if they work against
unions by being scabs.
I think there's definitely
a theme of segregation
or living patterns.
We saw that in the map,
and we also saw that
in some of the documents
about segregated work places.
And there might also be just
kind of a cultural theme here
about the differences between life
in the North and in the South.
We see that when our
newspaper letter writer
says he's worried about being hoodwinked,
and we see that when our Jazz singer
talks about she was
fooled and left behind.
We might even see that
with our perceptions
of black neighborhood life,
that African-Americans
may have gone from a system
of living very separately
in the South, to living in a very dense,
urban cultural area.
Where they may have met many different
African-Americans from all
different parts of the country.
I think another useful thing for us to do
is to think about some of
the major historical events
going on at that time period, that
we can connect to these documents.
A big one that comes to
mind is the great migration,
which we mentioned before.
Which was a period in
the early 20th century
when many Southern African-American's
pretty much had had it
with life in the South.
It was a combination of Jim Crow
segregation being legalized.
And also sharply declining
economic opportunities
that led thousands of
African-Americans to pack up
and head for Northern cities.
Now on of the reasons
that they could do this,
is because World War I was creating many
new factory jobs, just the way that
World War II would do later on.
And so there were many new
opportunities in the North
to draw African-Americans away to new
and even better paying jobs.
What else happened in this time period?
Well, there was the Supreme Court ruling
Plessy v. Ferguson,
which legalized segregation in 1896.
Which said that separate but equal
accommodations were constitutional.
The 1910s and 1920s
were times of increasing
modernity, but also a time of
cultural and racial backlash
as many new immigrants
streamed into the cities
along with African-Americans
from the South.
So there was also a
resurgence in the Ku Klux Klan
at this time period, which
President Woodrow Wilson
even kind of tacitly
approved of by watching
the film Birth of a
Nation in the White House.
And we might even talk about the
Chicago race riot of 1919
which is the race riot
mentioned in document four
when and you might even
mention the Chicago
race riot of 1919 which
was one of the deadliest
race riots in American history.
And this is the race riot that's
mentioned in document four
kind of gloatingly.
Alright, so we've identified
these three themes
that we might discuss in our essay.
Now the essay itself is about
changes and continuities.
So for each of these three things,
was there change over this time period
or was there continuity?
Well in labor you could say there's maybe
a change in type of labor.
But maybe many of the same problems
of race around labor.
Alright what about segregation?
Well I think there's both
segregation in the North
and in the South, but
again, it's kind of a
difference of type and degree.
So, segregation still exists in the North
but now it's taken on this urban form
where there are majority
black neighborhoods
and then other neighborhoods where
there are no African-Americans at all.
So a different type.
Alright, what about cultural changes?
We could see that in some cases,
African-Americans who moved North
missed their old society.
But then again, they certainly had
many problems when they were in the South.
Singing songs about how the boll weevil
and sharecropping had caused feelings
of dislocation and poverty.
So I think if there is a thesis statement
to be gotten out of this, it's that moving
from the South to the North,
African-Americans in the period from
1910 to 1930, experience pretty much
the same problems, but they
took different forms.
In the next video, I'll
talk about how we can turn
that into a really beautiful
and robust thesis statement
And then we'll go through the process
of outlining this essay.